[Music]
oh yeah I'm excited
hey you're excited about being on hot
breath yeah I'm excited about you know
however if me that's what's up
I don't even know you knew about it so
that's good yeah we out here man hey I
don't know I'm wondering people if I if
I meet you a person we talk or we we
exchange information I try and keep up
as much as I can that's what's up man
yeah we shot like a Bossip comedy thing
a few years ago you were hosting yeah
and that was that was that was the
beginning just one of yeah one of the
many things you've been doing but we're
in here in Atlanta right now what is
kind of your connection to Atlanta well
I was born in place not far from here
Chattanooga Tennessee mm-hmm so whenever
I can come this way I have family in the
area
but I came out here this trip working
with Ali Siddiq so no that's that's I'm
here yeah we from Houston so uh he was
out here for the weekend I was like ooh
I'll go hang out with my partner go work
it uptown and smell the busted pipes how
did you get from Chattanooga to Houston
uh my mom got a job but I was like nine
my dad quit his job he would this is
this is a funny story daddy quit his job
for my mama Rick drew his retirement
down moved to Houston with her in us
built her house and then she left him
the next year go and back single by team
by the time I was teams like it is cold
so were you performing as a kid and all
that still man do you know I I was never
a I don't have to the accolade to say I
was the funny dude in school I was never
that dude I was a good student I was in
theater and I did a lot of techy stuff I
did get a key for theater and acted in
theater cuz I school didn't have enough
people to do tech so I
actor annotate then I was losing a
journalism and television production
program so I was always kind of able to
do it like I was officially on the path
to do like journalism news casting
broadcasting yeah I used to announced
the basketball games but yeah I was
gonna be a black Marv Albert at one
point and then I just one day decided in
college that wasn't gonna be it no more
what changed I think um I got kicked out
of school
well my sophomore year I was I had it
there was just this is where you know
college you start meeting different type
of people I'm saying so I met this is
the first time I met somebody that was
just really into doing like scandalous
stuff one of my homeboys CP he was like
man you studying are hard you came party
you you worry about the wrong thing man
I said what you told my son and I work
in the Registrar's Office man
don't worry about this [ __ ] you gonna be
good and I was like okay he was serious
he called me one day and say hey me get
to the computer log in check he grades I
checked my grades he had changed all my
beads to AIDS and all my C's to B's I
had like a 3.7 GPA now my GPA wasn't bad
I was like a - 903 mm-hmm a B student
see I kept getting season man but yeah
he got me in Honors Program yeah yeah I
got 19,000 dollars worth of scholarship
money in nineteen thousand dollars worth
of scholarship money when you 18 years
old is a textbook sign for [ __ ] of
your life Wow so I was I was living
living life high for like two semesters
and then the school found out about it
and it became a big deal and they kicked
me out of school for a year and around
this time I started just picked up a job
at trying not to you know become a
destitute person in society and I hid it
from my parents they didn't know I was
out of school it didn't matter cuz they
didn't even give me no money for school
no way so I didn't really feel obliged I
had that conversation with dill so I was
waiting tables at this restaurant and
then I started hanging out and clubs
where they were doing comedy ed and one
of my good friends at the time his name
was energizer he started doing comedy
first and it was also tag along [ __ ]
that I was like all right I'm gonna go
with you
he was like yeah you need to get on his
comedy that's where the money
I'm like oh I shoes yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'm doing it tonight so he
went up and did it and I watched him he
was horrible I was like what he's
horrible I can be equally as horrible or
better than that and and that's how it
started you know then we met Ali and
that's like how our friendship started
like he was there from like day one and
the first day I said I want to company I
went on stage and I was I was lit up I
was drunk I was in his club and I got it
good it was one of those things where I
got a good response the first time but I
was drunk right he saw that and he was
like yeah okay yeah go talk to me
tomorrow yeah I was sober the next day
he came and I had to go sit in his
office and it was where he had an office
that was another thing the comedian with
a real full-blown office like a gun
nah but like a real office like you walk
in there is different different like
three different individual offices in an
open area so I walked in there it's 9:00
in the morning
yeah he's walk-in yeah that's not funny
walk back out so from like 9:00 to 11:00
I'm getting hazed on how to be a
comedian and man it was like I've the
tutelage started from there and so on
and then that was that's where I started
you know really developing everything I
was horrible
I was horrible when I first started I
don't have any fantastic stories about
destroying I was a monster I was a
problem I was horrible I remember there
was a day at this comedy club it was on
the north side of Houston it was called
the joint and I funny is Houston doesn't
have a lot of comedians but all the
comedian's that we have I'll be going to
be very well off like it's it's for its
weird interesting so uh there's me alley
this guy nephew Tommy Thomas miles from
The Steve Harvey Morning Show Kier
spates
Dave Lawson we are sitting outside the
comedy club and I just go out stage and
I bomb so bad and I used to dress up
like I've always dressed the same way
like even before I was funny I still was
always sharp so it was like dude with
the suit it was horrible I come outside
and they cure if you know kids baby he
was just sitting there he was he was
smoking
it's a goddamn shame and I don't I don't
know I don't know what I don't know it
say to you man and I'm like I'm fishing
for help like right you know the Thomas
you was like you know y'all gotta get
better man you know I bring people out
here to see us and me we can't we can't
put on shows like that that's one key
disjunction now now [ __ ] Thomas now
[ __ ] horrible keep doing this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] for you this [ __ ] ain't for
you you dress nice be a model do
something like just don't do this [ __ ]
no more this [ __ ] is not for you man
it's bad isn't horrible I don't know and
then I leave just walk around just like
shaking his head like why are you doing
this Wow and you know you just keep Tom
just keeps going and you keep writing
and keep bombing and weirdly enough you
keep the hang of it you either sink or
swim and I looked up stuff started
getting better I was able to implement
me doing characters and different stuff
to get better you know oh yeah I've been
taught that you got an epic boo story uh
okay so this is a funny story it's also
this is was weird as Ali has a through
line is showing up in many major moments
in my life so like so I want you to
school to do a comedy show prayer review
now I'm from Texas Southern University I
want the prayer for you to do this
comedy show and they had like you know
like Amateur Night
so it's me and another dude named Dante
Barrett that go down there to do this
comedy show now they had a hundred
dollar cash prize for you know people
who did the best or whatever so I I go
and the guy who announced me say yeah
he's from Texas Southern University a
start booing off the real like cuz it's
a rival school it's like saying oh you a
Philadelphian you say yeah he plays for
the Washington Redskins and he just
start bawling hey hey not having it so
I'm like my first joke was about Jesus I
was like me could you see if Jesus in
the club oh hey just booing some I don't
get him boo off Dan at this point people
start standing up with the booze and
pointing like get off like get out still
and then I said you know I'm saying [ __ ]
about them I just do being fat nah let
you know we going back and forth
roasters I get on stage and so Dante
sees he's like there's
crowd he proceeds to go on stage he does
alley whole sit and he'd kill him no he
killed a tourist he killing with
somebody else a whole material right so
we get out of state I said that's what
you're doing now so we in the car riding
back by hour and a half he's like man I
couldn't take it oh we're getting boo
just don't take the joke
did he win no he didn't win okay of
course he didn't win it's just the fact
that he did that he made it through that
one night so uh I said you know I'm
gonna give you I'm gonna give you three
days you better tie it tightly you do
the jokes for I tell him come on Manny
go beat Ruby I said hey man you better
tell him say you know get out here and
me gettin boo ya cuz I knew I knew it
was bad I know he was gonna get boo -
hmm and I had that feeling say yeah he
go get this boo so uh man I was it is
just we accept working at him and it
just started working out for me I
started doing sketches
oh yeah it was any sketches and I was
doing pranks I was just doing stupid
[ __ ] like taking people food and running
off and recording it recording it yeah
and you always had a camera around you
yeah yeah I mean I probably wanted a few
people to have they first booze on tape
I know I got my song yeah I got it in HD
somewhere it's a high definition you
know so even before it was trending you
had this vision for like content and the
power of it yeah and I think that was
because I was trained in television and
film and I I knew that it's [ __ ] is one
thing to say you funny but it's another
thing to be able to show somebody and
have a record of it and not which is
really good at keeping record of it so I
would document you know I knew how to
document things so I would document us
going on smile' road trips I was doing a
little stuff so um
needless to say when I'm ready to make
it one day I got some really good
footage that I'm gonna pull out she gets
stuff in the can the s live stuff in the
can um but what really started helping
me out though is I started doing
sketches online sketches and before
YouTube was out all the way you could
show somebody with sketches was like
play it on a DVD in front of a big
screen so what I would do is I'd get
some sketches I would do when I play
them in the club I knew some of the
promoters there
you play my stuff there and I got some
good results
I played sketches at my school during
like step shows or big performances and
then it started this the snowball effect
happen and well pivotal was I was I was
doing comedy got back in school and then
I joined this fraternity I became a
capital so they have real intense hazing
process and so me being a comedian in
trying to pledge a fraternity became
like oh they I've got a commuter line
say something funny and so I started
losing my fear of performing on the spot
I started losing my fear of being like
you know getting boo cuz you know
worrying about what people gonna think
the worst gonna happen is like I was
getting my ass kicked so they nobody
from kicked my ass at the show so it
should be fine
and I kept working at this spot this
place called the candy lady which was a
independently owned and operated comedy
club and one of my professors worked
there and another guy Kealing for route
he he was one of the owners of it and I
leave would be there and other guys in
the city and we would just work there
and it was kind of like where I was able
to really comedy camp really just get
better when I was on stage more
confidence more nose it was a real
constructive environment and it just
helped me get my feet up under me and
you know YouTube came out and I was able
to start with my sketches on YouTube and
then that's how I was able to really
reach other people in other places and
people knew who I was and then it the
room stopped being a room full of
strangers and people just like oh that's
to do that does this and then there was
a more warm environment and and that's
just what helped help build the process
there is those two different worlds
between likeness people who are funny
online and the people who are funny
right on stage and it is very much two
different world see this is the thing I
think what's underappreciated is the
artist and ER mm under appreciate it
because it's a it's it's becoming a lost
art amongst people who want to be funny
and it's really there's so much stuff
that that happens there's this the
artists stand up then there's the art of
storytelling which is an advanced and I
would say an advanced form a stand-up
coming you know stand-up is like let me
tell you this joke not
who's there is punched on timing but
then once you get those mechanics down
that fits your voice for who you are
then you can insert your life here
gotcha and that's that's where you start
seeing like wow I can I can talk to you
for 35 45 minutes on stage and it's like
well I don't feel like it's a disc but
I'm listening to a story that has a
beginning middle and end or something
that happened and you know the people
that were around me were really hard on
me like hey just tell him about your
life and my life was a very weird crazy
life so I think one thing that helps me
with crowd the crowd and I go to I've
experienced a lot of stuff so I'm not
judgmental person and then it my life
experiences can relate to people who've
experienced other things and you coming
up under alley who was without a doubt
one of the best storytellers in the game
and that was his thing and see I didn't
I didn't start off like being able to
tell stories like yeah this is like
maybe in the last two and a half three
years of working on storytelling mm-hmm
because I I was just I was a god became
a funny and I worked a lot of colleges
and a lot of time in college is hard to
tell a college crowd a story now like I
would tell him jokes and good I had good
hots it's and now was what I worked on
and you know now we've been touring here
recently me and the wild boys me Carlos
Miller from wildin out right now I we
were to go college to college and then
when you tell college kids stories and
they're funny then it's like oh [ __ ]
like you can do you can you can tell
them stories yeah you can get people
what are some maybe storytelling secrets
you've learned from working with people
like Ollie um tell the story from a real
place you'd never forget us you'll never
forget your story he really haven't
mm-hmm and I think that's the first
thing you sometimes I used to get mad
cuz they'd be like oh that's funny you
should talk about that and then I can't
see where the funny was I don't see
right and it's weird because you're
looking at it from this is the big laugh
and the big laugh is not always gonna be
something that's over the top parsley
unbelievable like when you start doing
comedy at first most people start trying
to figure out what can I say to get a
reaction or make and if you can see that
in conversation becoming a conversation
like if I can talk to you and make you
laugh in conversation then it slowly
becomes like that's what you stay on
stage that gets bigger like what is the
observation you made what the difference
between two things that really helped
change me what comedy was understanding
the difference between conceptual comedy
and observational comedy there's
conceptual comedy observational comedy
then storytelling three formats that you
can go to conceptual comedy is I'll give
you an example of a joke that everybody
knows but it's a concept and it works
it's it's it's conceptual conceptual
means um gun violence will go down if we
charge more for the bullet and bullets
was $5,000 and you see somebody shot
you'd be like oh he deserved that
he deserved to get shot Chris Rock
Marissa right now concept is if bullets
cost more then violence will go down
what I couldn't you can take that one
piece and put that concept in your head
and you're like damn it probably will go
down that's a concept that I put in your
head a plus B equals C concept
observation is have you ever seen this
person that does this I'm playing on you
experiences something that I experienced
you ever been on the train and you see
the person as does this blah blah blah
observation economy look at this
[ __ ] right here in the front row
he's got a fetch sensors and sunsets
observational comedy storytelling this
is what happened to meet his day I don't
care if it didn't happen to you but this
is what happened to me story now drew
that you're observing you you through
what you saw in your life and people are
gonna relate to that but at the same
time even if they don't relate to that
they're walking with you want your story
like oh wow I've never done it so
through your eyes I understand what that
experience is like and I gained a life a
life lesson and I guess filming filming
sketches also helps with like consent
conceptualizing stories yes okay cuz
because in order for a sketch to work
you have to have a concept that you're
trying to inject or point that you're
trying to make okay now something ones
that were really successful for me were
ones that that said hey this is what I
witnessed this is black girls do this
wipey
we do that such-and-such does this and
it was it was a very cookie cookie
cutter you know Hackney format and it's
become that now but originally it really
wasn't because nobody was really
utilizing that format but it was just a
way for us to quickly construct these
ideas and get him out like [ __ ] black
girls say that right blows up and goes
viral the video you do yeah and and I
did that video and not you know I never
did a part two there was never a part
par four of extra stuff it was just like
hey there was that concept it worked it
introduced a character I was always good
at doing characters and impersonations
so that was one of the things that
helped me you know get that ball rolling
and it adds to a layer of confidence
that you have of people saying I'm
coming to you as a friend and I want to
watch you to become entertained now
versus walking through this cold dark
smoky ass room and make me laugh and
those are two different places in and
it's from a place of a position of fear
and like now you don't walk into that
room feeling that way anymore you walk
in everyone feeling like I know y'all
y'all don't know me but I know y'all
y'all do know me once I start talking to
you it's something that I must say that
you will eventually say oh I get I know
where he's going
I experienced that and like I said it's
a lost art and people you can't shy away
from and it's not gonna die it's not
gonna die because as long as there's
television as long as there's long long
format
I always tell people are Tom's like you
know sketches and building your fan base
online is for promotion it's like
running a trailer to a movie okay but
you got to go why eventually go watch
the movie right it's like if I keep
showing you the trailer to Batman for a
Superman but I don't never bring the
movie out eventually gonna be safe all
right [ __ ] Batman for a super man I
won't go watch spider-man something I
need to see the movie cuz you got me to
that point and like you mentioned the
dudes stealing all these material but
you know just as well as well online
content can just be as easily stolen as
well yeah I've had a lot of stuff stolen
man long I guess was a big coat yeah I
mean that was a whole team you know
that's that's a two-hour story and it's
all
you get the sparknotes dasboard exactly
happen on that uh here's what happened I
was out with Duval doing some college
days mm-hmm and the video was getting
some good steam online on worldstar in
other places and getting millions of
views and I was doing with this guy
Derek Evans he's from Nashville he and I
were doing this man code thing and we
would just man should never do this then
we inserted traumatization act out and
those act outs was where people you know
on top of the laws and then it became
one of those things where I say on
Twitter what you think which I got for
me today suggestions take those
suggestions up so it became a very
interactive thing I taught to do Valle
about doing for uh appearing in the
sketch like you know like how I'm
appearing on your podcast right oh yeah
we'll do this and cool like three months
passes by and I get like phone call I
get message email people start sending
me stuff that's coming out I was like
hey man they're shooting this show up
here y'all you got a TV show on MTV in
like Wichita my mom and my homeboy in
New York like oh yeah oh yeah
congratulations y'all show got picked up
like what you talked about and man I
look up online and the the show has
clearly copied the sketch verbatim like
it wasn't uh always similar no no the
exact sketch the exact dramatization
they copied the format and then they
started adding other people didn't open
it up and made it not less of an urban
thing and made it just a broader
perspective approach on MTV so I call
you know friends got an attorney filed
an injunction against Viacom so right
after that ideas [ __ ] black girls say
that went viral so weirdly enough I
start getting your emails from MTV
different networks and so MTV mostly
like hey when you fly you to New York
wanna meet with you blah blah I'm like
okay cool I'm thinking it's got
something to do with what the file does
injunction that happened but really is
about this video so we talking they're
like oh we want to do some programming
with you blah blah blah blah and cool we
sitting in a closed environment like
this for people
me-me-me conversation
door opens up lady comes the end we're
gonna have to pause right now legals
gonna come in they let us know you have
an injunction for it again start my show
up here for
oh no we thought you know didn't you
know and so legal comes in he had his
whole conversation about how how does
this go away
well he started giving me opportunity to
present an opportunity opportunity well
you know when you have an issue with
Viacom you know we can't do anything
with your Comedy Central we can't do
anything with you abt can't do anything
at you at this so you have to you know
sign a waiver to remove the injunction
but we want to do things which is we
want to get you involved in this show
and this show and this show and this
project and I'm like alright do I try
and fight Goliath that's what I
should've did and I kind of pushed it in
was like you know what this gonna be
[ __ ] up the [ __ ] didn't call
back to the h and say hey um they stole
my [ __ ] show what shot dude and the
whole crew got our attorneys and
everybody was like hey man this is how
we do but see this is what happened when
you're a young boy you trying on my cue
to myself I'm in here he got [ __ ]
intimidated see he should have called
Nat Turner boom Ali Siddiq yeah yes
that's what I've been dealing with my
whole time
if that be brothers show oh so you want
to fight him so would you yeah what do
you settle like what a settle manner
being um two things happen one day no
giving us like right at $6,000 look for
the whole thing nothing all day just as
a piece just for like hey you know so
this is it work gave us some bread six
grand a TV show it was [ __ ] for the
whole thing Wow promises and some other
[ __ ] mm-hmm so you got money and then
promises
nothing legal nothing on paper nothing
written down not one attorney dis
muhfucka Wow head manager at the time
all right P he r.i.p know you had a
friend your frat brothers part of the
squad camry was like he was like Billy
listen listen to me I know you want to
fight these people you just got to be
smart you know I skipped a whole nother
part of the story that NT so I did I did
I did get getting get into it trippy
why's me and I'll go on of course first
thing I do I call Duvall no response no
answer I get on Twitter and um John
Stoll mushy blah blah
[Music]
he says you miss pac-man guess what
you're doing is what you want to do you
want do it this way
minam and if it was one thing I learned
from that it's like he pick and choose
your battles differently okay it's one
thing I could tell you was like you know
in in television in Hollywood it doesn't
work the way the street work the way you
think it does
it's is different it's it's it's a
different process it's a different beast
it's a different animal everybody feel
like they wanna be safe so if you would
have said a X Y Z and then we would have
put the streets on it then it had been
in a been different situation you see
how when somebody slapped drink and then
the streets call then all of a sudden
they throw festivity throwing a party
for Drake I was on the same for that's
laughter and then Street streets mean a
lot oh you put what in she treats me in
a lot steal my [ __ ] show and
watch what happened in the street
okay but it's merely from the streets
Chattanooga's he got people he got
people
you ain't you probably not from the
street but it's a mine [ __ ] with you and
I'm here you call me yeah it like this
why planning for your neighborhood
[ __ ] he with the streets and Siwon
Encinas is when you become accessory to
salts and batteries right there
I knew all right I knew if I call him
this one that ain't that ain't gonna be
a meeting at all it's gonna be somebody
just getting set on fire some trash cans
getting through to some windows so some
people getting beat up yeah in it and
and there's one thing I had to learn it
was like you know it's a different way
I probably it's a different way of
dealing with this okay I you know to
where the fingers ain't gonna solve it
being angry gonna solve it he's just
understanding how Hollywood works and
that was my first lesson on Hollywood
101 link hey what did happen good out of
it they sent me over to BT they want to
be with me BT offered me a red carpet
hosting position
hey we want to do this project which you
once you we want you to host the red
carpet at V T award cool it goes a
mildly from journalism I agree I do it
and you were a correspondent with them
back in the day to around see when I was
in high school yeah I did a
correspondent [ __ ] with bt 14 summit and
this was years ago like I had PBT came
to the school in a funny part was like
when I first got the Hollywood book
about one to really work in the industry
I was in high school and that's how I
college I said I didn't have to worry
about like getting the money from my
parents to go to school well I got in
this program with ABC and ABC had a
producers fellowship where you can write
and produce television program so I did
that fellowship for a year they gave me
like 40 grand and go to school and
that's how I went to school and I went
out to LA I met with them I work with
them I had a producer
Melvin McCray who produced a wordless
tonight with Peter Jennings I went there
saw a live taping it at a couple times
in New York and so I kind of knew I was
gonna leave Houston and work in this
industry mm-hmm it was just a matter of
how am I gonna go about doing it and
sometimes you go on journeys that you
don't understand why are you going
through it but you got to understand and
you learn some of those lessons and then
it comes full circle later on
and you know the red carpet thing with
bt opened up a lot of doors helped me
meet a lot of people and you it's it's
one thing about this about this game
it's not a today game it's not a right
now game it's a slow cook it's a slow
build and the lasting people who last
you know in the industry
you're gonna have multiple levels on
which you're gonna meet somebody like I
met you on that but we sitting here
talking on this but then you don't know
what the next level is we gonna work in
the next capacity yes but it'll all go
back to the first time we met each other
on their boxer project mm-hm and that's
just that's just how that's just how it
works
so long story short with the man code
guy code thing injunction drop I worked
on that it just became on a lot of
different projects became hard to work
with certain people because you got such
this be finish in the street with a
person and I there's a lot of
opportunities I feel like I wasn't able
to get on a do because I was a yes to do
they got the problem with it such a
session but I worked on a whole bunch
other different levels and he comes
around full circle
you'll get blackballed from some
projects even though you was the one
that was in the right because they want
to work with somebody else okay screw
that this person [ __ ] over you and
we're gonna help him [ __ ] over you um
but you know we know you talented we
know that you [ __ ] wrote this project
but we're gonna still [ __ ] squeeze
you out and didn't tell you all if you
don't do this and then put on this this
label on you that you have a problem I
have a problem for a [ __ ] real reason
Eames and it's like the lady how you mad
at her about she getting [ __ ] raped
with butter in the movie that she don't
know this happening but you [ __ ]
pissed at her I didn't [ __ ] know he's
gonna put bun in my ass and rape me but
you mad at me
what type of [ __ ] is that I get right
but you made the butter rape I miss that
Marlon Brando did a movie
Last Tango in Paris and there's the
infamous rape scene in which a 19 year
old girl who's actress and they got it
they got Oscar nominations for this
movie and it Hollywood acclaim for this
rape scene and but it turns out now it's
a real rape oh wow
it was a real right thing he's not a
real rape just now this it was a real
baby Wow real rape oh my god he decided
butter in our ass you can look at the
interview online you could put you can
look at the interview uh-huh online and
he's admitted to it and then the
audience has his [ __ ] disgusting
laugh because he said oh we both looked
at the butter we knew what we wanted and
then they laugh and they and he said he
didn't want the girls reaction as a
actress he wanted as a real girl getting
right but I'm [ __ ] acting wow I'm not
a real girl in the street getting raped
Ilia scaring me hey we'll get him in the
hot seat next he's it's very passionate
yeah he is he is in person come up under
though man look learners imagine just
imagine coming out stage and somebody
talking to you like that
it's like good coaching knows like right
it's like it's like rocky without Mickey
it's over rock you gotta you gotta put
your hands up you gotta fight
there's no tomorrow that was that was
what that was and so on
despite all the Viacom stuff it seemed
to also have kind of charged you up and
just to continue to blaze your own Trail
well yeah I think I definitely took a
note that you know Houston in the city
that gets a lot of attention for
anything really it's a city that people
go to and make a lot of money at its
very largest market but I just kept
blazing my own trail doing my own thing
continuously working it didn't stop
really in specials doing 30 doing stuff
online because at the end of day what I
started realizing I looked at I looked
at one one game that has that gave me
some blueprint I looked at how rappers
do stuff
they put our projects they put out free
mixtapes why do they start doing that
because they knew that it was more
important for people to listen to them
and know who they are
didn't get money from them and they
still not know who they are like the
goal was that it was free and then it's
four kids are free kids don't want to
spend money they just want to be
entertained so but they will do is
they'll give you word-of-mouth they'll
tell so-and-so they'll tell somebody
else because they got time to do that
when you're older you'll pay for some
[ __ ] for what you like because you know
what you like kids don't know what they
like so they watch every [ __ ] thing
interested and then the [ __ ] that they
like they share and I might like
something but I'm not gonna be on my
high horse shouting out y'all need to go
listen to such and such album and do
this and do that but they are the truest
purest form of fanbase because their
mind is it congested with bills I don't
have time to do this thinking like hey I
dare a hedonist in in many ways they
just seeking them the best pleasures out
of life from 18 orally from like 17 to
like 24 you were just a pure hedonist
you are strictly looking for the things
I'm drinking I'm having sex I'm doing
drugs I'm listening to music I'm in the
arts like I'm whatever I can do that's
all my own time and that's what makes
them the best critics that's what makes
them at the best and it's it's it's
interesting because every every so every
so many years the the climate changes
for or the appetite changes for what
they want the line is is it's pushed
further do you know the the metaphors
and similes that they use in music are
definitely more intense as time has
progressed now storytelling how long he
see well I mean we've got to have a
situation he about to come over here cuz
hey I'm not saying oh you know why it is
not more intense because they have
rappers don't have the intensity to be
able to tell a story I mean listen to
our ever and I can hear the stories and
the metaphors and similes are still
better they're like you know just give
you one from from my man rock him rock
him say he and he in the streets and he
has a beef and he sees his God
now he pulls up in buckshots to scraping
the concrete I'm saying then he gon NWA
I pulled up and I did a drive-by
nunchakus person in saying different
things you know even with even being
able to teaching education poor
righteous teachers we got to do open the
rap he say led us to words words the
phrases to paragraphs
that's how things go you learn let us do
you learn words then you learn phrase
then you learn paragraphs I'm saying so
it's it's like they don't think now I'm
saying so the metaphors are [ __ ]
awful I know what you're talking about
by everything that you saying but if I'm
listening to rock him and rock him say
this is how good I am you can take 20 mm
you take seven emcees put them in a line
you take seven more rappers who think
they can rhyme
it'll take seven more before I go for
mine that's 21
MCS ate up at the same time so again I
think it's interesting to see how time
progresses and appetites change as I
expressed as a 10-year gap between us
you know I'm saying it's a solid 10 year
gap and so it's stuff that I was doing
that he didn't do your stuff he did I
didn't do anything this guy's it's under
us that's doing different stuff but
that's just how it goes
yeah you know you got a thing none of us
can tap dance or sing at all but you got
think Sammy Davis jr. when he did a
comedy he'd know how to tap dance you
know I seen he said he could but you
know but he was to come it's even older
not I mean he was all of them was
singers the whole crew the whole
pack with singers dancers actors in in
on comics yeah but they wouldn't listed
as common things like we're gonna see
Frank Sinatra Danny start bringing the
right back divas cast it like Don
Rickles
yeah don't wreck oh yeah you don't Danny
learning he wasn't far right back either
that was Frank Knox boy mm-hmm yes right
hand man right no one the only guy that
can make fun of Sinatra was Don Rickles
nacho not to refuse go to the White
House if he couldn't bring Bob yeah
that's destined we wanted to bring with
him but yeah I mean like that that's one
thing that I've learned about it with
with social media is that those are the
advantages that we had i came up when
there was no social media and then in
the midway point of my career it
appeared so that was something that i
took to and was able to use to my
advantage you had the foresight to ask
social media to what do you like I'll
just do that
right and then you know there was stuff
where I would sit and I would talk to
them because it became a thing it was as
much of it was entertainment as it was
education for me but when I was learning
what my audience was I was learning who
I was speaking to I was learning like
how do i how do I grow this thing and
then I think there's a point where I
kind of you know there's so much stuff
you have taken and stolen and lack of
originality before you like all right
let me just fall back let me work on
this because I'm out clearly if this is
a problem for me people taking and I
didn't understand how to receive someone
taking now because I felt like that was
all I had mm-hmm but once you realize no
that's not all you have and that's not
all you are and for somebody to take
they have to appreciate and even if they
can't articulate that they took from you
they took from you subconsciously
meaning that your ripple of what you put
out shape somebody's life who they watch
which is subconsciously how it is people
say imitation is the best form of
flattery
mm-hmm when you young and you don't know
how you don't you don't know who you are
you don't know how to receive that it's
become for anger think about it Elvis
and Michael Jack Michael Jackson got
people to this day dressing
and doing them whole they hold thing Dan
out here getting mad jumping out the
grave or when they were alive right
people about it like don't do me like
that
no they did they understood that I am
I'm this person and this is what I said
about and what is what I said in motion
and you and you inspired by me cool I
didn't know how to deal with being an
inspiration for somebody to draw from
but I drew from other people you know so
as I got older I'm able to accept they
didn't understand that part well thank
you so much for all that wisdom and I
mean it really adds a new perspective
just on social media and social media
can be a distraction but it also be a
tool so it's cool to hear how you use as
a tool and in clearly you know once I
got older to understand it I was able to
look at how I knew how Hollywood work I
was able to take the blame off of being
mad at Duvall like you did this and you
took this from me he ain't making no
shows he's not the greenlighter it is
like you know when I know how show works
it's somebody who somebody is in the
office looking for a concept that they
can make work for somebody probably had
no idea you know I'm saying I'm giving
benefit of the doubt
I'm offering like hey we've seen each
other since Danny ain't no beef but it
was a it was a lesson learned in life on
how to deal with things because when you
have your moment to shine you just want
to shine in your moment
you don't want ten people trying to step
on your shine and for your moment
everybody gonna have a moment so people
gonna have two or three moments and
that's what this game was about you know
that's where you learn how to share our
being on funniest wins of Marla's Wayne
Marlon Wayans I learned hey man you know
got to know your audience know who you
speaking to but also understand it's a
team dynamic working with Nick it's a
team dynamic
mmm-hmm it ain't just you be funny and
blaze everybody it's no you you say
something about me I say something about
you now we're giving them a show but if
it's one side this is trash I don't want
to watch this you know what I mean
mm-hmm
like I learned how to share the room
improv teaches you that in my improv
training hey we're doing this together
ain't no me matter how funny I am if the
story that we're telling together
doesn't make sense then what do people
get they don't get anything
well thank you for your time and I'm an
appreciating your man before we get out
of here is there anything else you want
the world to know
Billy sir rails check out my youtube
channel
laughs share comment like subscribe
check me out life I'm everywhere trying
to do this comedy thing and I'm out of
you and now on hot breath I breath well
Thank You Billy sir else yeah we made it
no I did I always like to prepare and
that's right yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
I breath